أجنبي كبير الدبلوماسيين الإماراتيين في إسرائيل
للاحتفال بمرور عامين على توقيع
اتفاقيات إبراهيم التي تطبيع
العلاقات بين إسرائيل والعديد من
الدول العربية ، كان من المقرر أن يلتقي الشيخ عبد الله الثنائي
برئيس
الوزراء الإسرائيلي يلابيد اليوم في القدس في
وقت سابق.  سفير دولة الإمارات في
المملكة المتحدة وسأله عما
يأمل وزير الخارجية
تحقيقه خلال زيارته
أعتقد أنها استمرار كما
قلتم في الذكرى السنوية الثانية
لاتفاقات أبرام مثل هذه
الخطوة التحويلية داخل المنطقة
من حيث بناء السلام.  من حيث
فتح الفرص للشباب الذي
تعرفه ، وكل هذه الأمور سوف
تتضاعف
ويقود سموه هذا الأمر كما تعلمون في هذا
الملف بالذات ، وهو أمر بالغ الأهمية كما
تعلمون وأعتقد أننا نحتاج أيضًا إلى
إعادته إلى  الملك تشارلز ، أنت تعلم أنه يفتح
الكثير للشباب وهذه هي
الأهمية هناك لذا فإن الإمارات العربية المتحدة تحت
إشرافنا.  الرئيس أه
مصافحة ولكن أيضًا عبد الله نوع من
حمل تلك الرسالة التي تظهر
حماس الطاقة والالتزام بالاتفاقات
أمر حيوي